What explains North Korea's relentless
quest for nukes and missiles? These
programs are obviously not some
bargaining chip! And regime survival is
hardly their only purpose. My take? The
North Korean regime intends eventually
to fight a limited nuclear war in the
Korean Peninsula – and win it.
Pyongyang plans confrontations it can
win. The North Korean regime is not
suicidal! It could not have lasted this
long if it were. Its threats and
provocations are never sudden,
impulsive outbursts.
They're always carefully planned –
rehearsed well in advance. If Pyongyang
can force an American president to blink
in a future Korean crisis, then the
US-South Korean military alliance will
collapse. US forces will be out and the
Kim family regime will take a giant step
towards settling the still-unfinished
Korean War on its terms. All the pieces
for the North's design are slowly but
deliberately falling into place:
the nukes, the missiles, the cyber war
component. America and her allies must
wake up to that design and counter it
while there is still time.
To learn more
about my take on North Korea, check the
links in the description below. Also, let
us know what other topics you want our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and be
sure to subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI.